Two more technical details
about Word 2 Vec and
about methods to learn
embeddings in general.
First, because of the way embeddings are
trained, it's often better to measure
the closeness using a cosine
distance instead of L2, for example.
That's because the length
of the embedding vector
is not relevant to the classification.
In fact, it's often better to
normalize all embedding vectors
to simply have unit norm.
Second, we have the issue of
trying to predict words, and
there are lots of them.
So in Word 2 Vec we have this set up,
we have a word that we're going to embed
into a small vector, then feed that into
a simple linear model with weights and
biases and
that outputs a softmax probability.
This is then compared to the target
which is another word in the context
of the input word.
The problem of course is
that there might be many,
many words in our vocabulary.
And computing the softmax function of
all those words can be very inefficient.
But you can use a trick.
Instead of treating the softmax as
if the label had probability of 1,
and every other word
had probability of 0,
you can sample the words
that are not the targets,
pick only a handful of them and act
as if the other words were not there.
This idea of sampling
the negative targets for
each example is often
called sampled softmax.
And it makes things faster
at no cost in performance.
That's all there is to it.
You take your large corpus of texts,
look at each word, embed it, and
predict its neighbors.
What you get out of that is
a mapping from words to vectors
where similar words are going to
be close to each other.